all right okay so as you can see i have
a timer on my phone you're making me
nervous
you're gonna do it you're gonna be great
i can feel like those tests that i took
in like high school
[Music]
i'm gonna push start and then we're
going to have some fun okay okay ready
what movie does
what movie does robert de niro's famous
line you talking to me come from
taxi driver great
all right where was aretha franklin born
detroit
no
yes no she oh chica uh
his church is in chicago chicago
[Music]
south
atlanta
i don't know i know where dr cleveland
was born
memphis tennessee perfect okay
number three rydo high school is the
setting for which influential
70s degrees
yes
no see this is yeah come on more theater
right you're the one that i want titus
right thank you girl
how many total grammys did aretha
franklin win oh come on
all of them
i love it that's a win for in my book
that's a point question
five julie andrews won the best actress
oscar for which 1964 musical sound of
music
the other one
cinderella
that's 58.
oh [ __ ]
it's just
mary some like it hot oh god
she won the oscar for mary poppins
yeah so that's our round oh god
you scored 500 it was amazing no
ask me another one
okay we'll do another okay
you're gonna get this one okay
hamilton
[Music]
you